[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les
titres à l'occasion de la journée
mondiale de la trisomie 21 qui se
déroule aujourd'hui nous recevons
jacques costil président de
l'association française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21
avec qui nous ferons un point sur ce
syndrome et puis issy paris hand
affrontera brest le 25 mars au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec
l'ambition d'attirer plus de 5000
spectateurs record actuel d' influence à
ce niveau nous parlerons de ce challenge
avec jean-marie cifre président d'ici
paris hand faire évoluer le regard sur
la trisomie 21 c'est le sens de la
journée mondiale qui se tiendra qui se
tient aujourd'hui une occasion de
rassembler parents personnes atteintes
chercheurs médecins et professionnels
nous en parlons avec notre invité
jacques costil président de
l'association française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21
bonjour nous avons tenu un colloque ce
week-end à grenoble qu'il vous aime
ou colloques que nous organisons car la
frc l'association française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21
hays chez cette journée le 21 mars 2000
sacs l'appareil et depuis nous organiser
nous sommes à l'organisation de fêtes
que colloque nous avons en avant lundi à
limoges à lui aura versé à marseille en
2016 la grenade cette année et voilà on
a pu avoir quelques nouvelles bonnes
nouvelles
enfin laboratoire français installés en
espagne
donc ça avance voilà la recherche avoir
depuis des années nous finançons nous
avons financé la recherche au sein de
l'université paris diderot qui améliore
cher sur des souris avec un extrait de
thé vert est ainsi composé qui s'appelle
le déchet j'ai agi sur agen dire qu'à a
gelé souvent dit ici et mais au bout de
deux ans de travail mené par le
professeur rappelle il assuré en espagne
un produit qui s'appelle le fond top que
j'ai ici mais je les ai eu quelques
jours dans la poche et que fait-il je la
connais bien
alors oui ca il a la balle du thé vert
c'est une boisson chocolatée compléments
alimentaires médicaments et il ya
meilleur le cognitives et le
comportement dans notre numéro sur le x
fragile et on porte qu'il agira dans
d'autres maladies
hacker lesquelles lord autre forme de
déficience intellectuelle qui sont
encore méconnus puisque castrés reçoit
des discussions intellectuelles sont
méconnus donc aujourd'hui un produit qui
va cubain on a vu en vo il en est qu'à
ses débuts et donc nous on y va
voilà alors donc c'est une sans espoir
parce que c'est vrai que si cette
journée je sais que des parents ont déjà
commencé à en prendre et en utah sont
positifs à son tour ah oui à son projet
deux ans dit il quand même en espagne où
tu as donné 100% de réussite
alors bien sûr il faut quand même aller
voir son médecin avant parce que le
riche c'est le prendre du poids on sait
déjà que dans la semi documentaire où
ils sont pas maigre
sauf que sauf dans l'isère c'est à dire
les versements ou autour des personnes
assez fine avec une cuisine et pour qui
la seule raison c'est qu'il faut
beaucoup de ce qui manque du sport
ce qui fait que voilà ça leur permet de
d'avoir il
alors pour les téléspectateurs qui
serait pas au fait de la trisomie 21 ans
que déjà vous pouvez nos coeurs je suis
une petite définition de cette
pathologie c'est dû à quoi exactement
or la crise mais retient à la première
cause génétique de retard mental
ap étant plus de 5 millions de personnes
dans le monde
ces individus montrent une altération
conique yeux
je voulais parler et après un séquençage
entier du chrono au maintien en 2000 qui
a permis le développement de modèles de
souris transgéniques et d'études de
l'expression des gènes entre copines
dans un contexte russie maintient les
recherches actuelles portent
l'amélioration du déficit d'accord ans
clame donc cognitives bien sûr et on
travaille également de construire en
parallèle avec la maladie alzheimer qui
prend naissance sur la même chaîne était
pas mais est donc en finance on a pu
n'en sait rien d'eux veut une personne
ses capés une recherche la mayade
d'alzheimer excuses musée à laon finance
aussi la conception d'un matériel pour
détecter les problèmes de sommeil au chu
de grenoble donc ses 15000 euros aux
trois ans 5000 euros par an que l'on va
financer ils ont volé aux finances aimé
et dans dans le bon sens il ya aussi
d'autres
écusson année qui sont sur la peau les
problèmes de pause ont des boutons sont
closes du mal à soigner
donc voilà il ya encore il ya encore
beaucoup de travail à mener dans la
spéciale pour la pour améliorer la vie
quotidienne de ces personnes eh bien
merci monsieur costil et en voleur le
combat continue
oui je suis jamais fui hockey en passant
tout autre sujet issy paris hand
affrontera brest le 25 mars au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec
l'ambition d'attirer plus de 5000
spectateurs record actuel d'affluence à
ce niveau pour en discuter avec nous ce
soir jean-marie cifre président d'ici
paris hand je n'ai pas oublié
alors pari réussi pari en passe d'être
réussi
avant tout je voudrais dire un mot parce
que effectivement j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer monsieur en vous attendant et
ayant eu de serre trisomique eu très
sensible à ce qui vient de se dire et à
toute cette action et je vais on a
échangé nos contacts et on va on va
rester en contact
maintenant pour revenir au rang de balle
effectivement on a un challenge
extrêmement important de remplissage
dans un territoire qui n'est pas le
nôtre puisque notre territoire est
plutôt ici il voue une eau bien le stade
pierre de coubertin dans le xvième
puisque ce sont nos terrains de jeu
habituel nom de match également deux
matches également d'entraînements et de
matches et est là à la faveur de deux du
territoire ici qui nous sollicitent
patrick chehab notamment l'ancien
président de comité 78 qui nous
sollicitent depuis des années pour faire
un match sur son territoire nous avons
évoqué ce sujet là au vélodrome de saint
quentin qui est un qui est une enceinte
olympique donc très prestigieuse pour
réaliser ce majeur balle qui est un
match officiel de première division
contre brest avec qui nous sommes
actuellement second essai court mouchoir
de poche voilà dans un mouchoir de poche
donc un match qui va être
un match exceptionnel en qualité
puisqu'il ya d'excellentes joueuses
brest une excellente équipe avec
d'excellentes joueuses à s y paraît
aussi ici paris on les a vus faire de la
promotion à se passer à magny les
hameaux
oui elles ont fait beaucoup de promotion
sur le territoire donc le pari est en
passe d'être réussi
nous nous refusons beaucoup de place
actuellement avant carrément et donc on
pense arriver autour de 5000 3 puisque
au delà de la capacité du vélodrome
potentiel actuel en configuration
cyclisme puisque là il s'agit de
construire un terrain sur le terre-plein
central avec des loges autour et pour
lévis et donc ça va augmenter la
capacité de du public mais dites moi pas
avait réussi vous allez leur faire que
souvent où il ya quelque chose de prévu
c'était juste un pari c'est pas c'est
pas juste un pari c'est un challenge à
shell a annoncé un challenge
j'avoue que quand au début des
discussions
bon ok on va on va jouer le drame de
saint quentin c'est super maintenant
pour remplir il faut remplir faut
séduire un public qui n'est pas notre
public habituel
après la ferveur face au vent bien
supérieur faso en augmente des résultats
des équipes de france et puis les
résultats également conçu on est suivi
on a effectivement des joueuses
exceptionnelles qui sont suivis dans le
monde entier donc effectivement on fait
venir du public c'est très très sympa
mais la suite c'est ça fonctionne la
suite voulez vous avez un petit sourire
puisque la quasi impossibilité que ça
soit fait plus souvent ans personne ne
regarde la centrale non non mais
effectivement nommés
en créer des événements dans la
récurrence c'est toujours bien puisque
effectivement quand un événement devient
récurrent on crée des habitudes ont créé
un public et c'est donc pourquoi pas
imaginer de faire un match de
championnat par an sur le territoire et
au vélodrome de saint quentin pour oxz
mais pourquoi pas essayer de s'y est dit
si bien amené et j'en avais discuté donc
mais tout le monde tout le monde est
très favorable à nous accueillir
on a vu la promotion vos joueuses sont
venus à magny les hameaux si je me
trompe pas ça leur tient à coeur c'est
dans l'idée de l'équipe d'issy paris de
cette promotion d'aller chercher les les
écoliers les gens alors oui on est on
est on est vraiment on développe et on
tient à nos valeurs de respect
d'engagements d'esprit d'équipé de
partage et donc partager partager avec
on a des joueuses encore une fois
exceptionnelle sur des joueuses
professionnelles partager avec le public
partagé avec les écoles sont allés faire
des cours dans des dans les classes
partager avec le grand public faire
connaître notre discipline signer des
autographes ça fait ça fait partie de
leur de leurs gènes elle adore faire ça
elle adore donner à ce tout ce public
qui nous rend qui nous rend bien pendant
les matches et sait aussi faire la
promotion du handball féminin quand même
vous attirer du monde
oui le handball féminin par rapport aux
garçons étaient un petit peu moins connu
mais tout le monde que nous amenons au
match de handball féminin sont
totalement séduit et reviennent donc
voilà on a honte qu'on doit on doit se
faire encore mieux connaître sur le plan
de la médiatisation qu'on travaille
beaucoup là-dessus remplissage
notabilisation régulation partenaires
c'est notre triptyque pour fonctionner
et pour faire vivre le club
c'était un pari un challenge mais vous
saviez que ça allait fonctionner quand
même
oui parce que ça vous pas au début au
début challenge on sait pas mais on
attend on se bat pour le réussir
et effectivement mais on s'est tous
battu les collectivités le land bâle ii
du 78e handball d'île de france s'est
mobilisée et tous les acteurs se sont
complètement mobilisée pour pour ce
match là eh bien merci monsieur cifre le
ici pavie horde contre brest c'est
samedi c'est bien ça à quelles heures à
18 heures vous y serez
malheureusement non parce que je suis
très pris je suis déjà pris avec mais
ceci je voulais comme celle avec ici par
guy recueillis hier jean monnier une
réflexion avec une personne de qui je
travaille et on se disait on se serait
bien de trouver une marraine ou un
parrain et justement on y évoquait le
monde se bouge jure que c'est vrai et
bien pris et que j'étais viré que vous
êtes bien entouré par la mer dit voilà
je vous jure que c'est vrai et barco on
évoqué que ce sport était et avait un
engouement actuellement et que c'est
quelque chose qui était parce que les
pasteurs de balai et voilà nos valeurs
et longuement là pourquoi pas et bien
grâce à cette vitalité vous allez
pouvoir peut-être créer un lien en tout
cas merci d'être venu sur ce plateau
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]